ويليام فور ايه معلم الفرنسيه شاب يعيش
ويعمل في السعوديه لفت الانظار على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ويليام نشرت سلسله من
مقاطع الفيديو التي يظهر فيها بالزي
السعودي التقليدي ويتحدث العربيه بطلاقه
ويلتزم بالعادات والتقاليد في محادثاته
مدرس اللغه الفرنسيه المقيم في الرياض قدم
رؤيته الخاصه للسعوديه التي اعجب بتفاصيل
الحياه فيها وبالعادات والتقاليد واستطاع
الاندماج مع السعوديين وتكوين صدقات كبيره
معهم من مختلفه احب السعوديه بعد زيارته
الاولى للحج اعجبه حينها باللغه العربيه
وقرر ان يدرسها في الجامعه بفرنسا ثم بدا
في كتابه روايه باللغه العربيه
لكنه هو ذهب الى ابعد من ذلك بكثير على ما
يبدو الحين انا اشرب الشاي في المتحف
النائف في المدينه الجبه ما شاء الله ما
شاء الله المتحف رائع جدا جدا
من عمري واكتشفت السعوديه بطريقه الحاج
همم الناس في هذا الزمان كنت انا كنت لا
تتحدث اللغه العربيه
وعلى التقيت بالسعوديين وكنت اريد ان
اتحدث معهم ولكن لا استطيع هذا السبب رجعت
علامه اللغه العربيه
وحصلت على الماجستير واا عدت الى السعوديه
همم خاصه في الرياض ليمارس اللغه العربيه
واا نعم وليام ما هذا لغتك العربيه ممتازه
يعني تكاد تكون افضل من العرب انفسهام على
كل حال اليوم عيون السياح لها نظره مختلفه
عن عيون اهل البلد لتفاصيله فما ابرز
مالفتك في السعوديه كفرانسي قادم الى
السعوديه اولا
اه السعوديه
هي بره الرحمن هي بلد السعاده هي بلاد
الامان وانا انصح الفرنسيه
والشعب السعوديه اللطيفه جدا
اقول السلام عليكم واهلا وسهلا الى شخص
سعودي نسوي العلاقات
[موسيقى]
اللغه ولا تتحدثها بطلاقه فقط ولكن تحرس
على التزام بالتقاليد السعوديه والعدد
السعوديه وحتى الظهور بالزي التقليدي كمان
نشاهدك اليوم ونشاهدك على مواقع التواصل
من خلال فيديوهاتك ليش تحب ازيك
طيب انا انا اعتقد السعوديه هي يجوز زي
الهويه انا فرنسي اصلي من كل اجدادي 100%
ولكن انا اتحدث اللغه العربيه لانني احب
السعوديه عشان اكتشفت اهل السعوديه في
السعوديه والحين انا ادرس اللغه الفرنسيه
الى الطلاب السعوديين وانا فخور فخوره جدا
واذا انا عندي الاخلاص مثلا عندما البس
الزي السعودي انا انا اعتبره ذلك كما
اخلاص الاخلاص في الكلام وقوه الكلام
وهذا الشباب انا فخور مثلا الاقل تمثال
الفقر فخر العرب وهذا السبب انا فخوره جدا
ويشرفني كثيرا مثلا عندما اراء السعوديين
يلبس البداله الفرنسيه في فرنسا
وانا اريد السعوديون لديهم نفس السعاده
ونفس الشرف عندما يراني بالزي السعودي